George: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between 7-Eleven in Japan and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
In Japan, our coffees come in regular --
Joe: In small, medium,
large,
George: And large.
and extra large.
If you're getting coffee,
why not grab a chocolate doughnut?
Our 7-Eleven drinks come in
sizes of 200 milliliters,
450 milliliters,
and 1 liter,
and 1.5 liters.
I'm sorry, I couldn't get it.
[laughing maniacally]
In the US, we have Big Gulps,
self-service fountain drink for sodas,
and they come in these four sizes:
medium, large, extra large,
double extra large.
[air horn rings]
So, I want to see how
much the biggest-size cup
I could get at the 7-Eleven is.
And to do that, I will need, hang on ...
It's just past 40.
It's exactly 48 ounces.
That's hardly double extra.
I'll round it up, 'cause
of this section here.
I'll round it up to 50.
7-Eleven also at one point offered a size
that was even bigger,
called the Team Gulp,
which, again, according to them,
was 128 fluid ounces
for your team,
'cause who doesn't like
to, after a softball game,
go to 7-Eleven, get a
Team Gulp and 10 straws?
You know, just kick it
with the boys, right?
Come on, team.
Yeah, right. That's for one
person, don't be ridiculous.
Here are many, many, many 7-Eleven items
you can get in the US
you can't get in Japan.
And here are many of the 7-Eleven items
exclusive to Japan.
Japan puts the "convenience"
in the convenience store.
We call it konbini,
which is the abbreviation
of the convenience store,
and it makes our life a lot easier.
For example, office workers
rely on stores like 7-Eleven
for food and drink to keep them happy
so that they can be productive at work.
And for students, they tend
to buy juices and snacks
and hot foods, instant noodles, you know.
And when I was a kid, I would often eat
hot foods and instant noodles
with my friends and
with my ex-girlfriends.
7-Eleven memories.
And for families, there is pretty much
every daily essential they may need.
And also you can pay your bills,
get ticket reservations
for music and sports,
7-Eleven even has its own bank and ATMs.
No matter where you go, especially
in big cities like Tokyo,
you can find more than one
konbini on every block.
Yeah, it's a bit different here in the US.
I do frequent 7-Eleven, and it's not bad,
but the vibe is more kind of like
get the thing you need and go.
The food is usually pretty hit or miss,
usually miss in my experience.
The hot food looks like it's
been sitting out for a while,
so I usually don't get it.
Since there are way too many
items exclusive to Japan
for us to buy for one episode,
so I've curated some of
my favorites for you guys.
This is still a ton of food.
So, here we have Japanese onigiris.
This one is plum,
tuna mayonnaise,
shrimp and mayonnaise,
mentaiko, which is spicy cod roe.
I picked these onigiris from the back,
because onigiri in the
back are fresh of all time.
And let me show you how to open this one.
Just pull this over till here ...
Like this, so that you can have
the dried seaweed.
Itadakimasu.
Mm, a little bit sweet,
a little bit of sour.
So, here is our sushi.
Look at this huge salmon sushi.
Ah!
Gorgeous. Gorgeous sushi.
Itadakimasu.
Oh, my God, this is so delicious.
Mm.
Osushi!
We've got this long natto roll.
Personally, I love natto.
But even Japanese people,
50% of them like it, 50%
of them don't like it.
This is an acquired taste.
So, after this sticky
and smelly natto roll,
I've got sushi roll special package.
So when it comes to this
one, it's called oinarisan.
It has rice inside,
and the skin is a sweet tofu skin.
Mm!
I'll admit, oinarisan umai wa.
This is so good.
So, my grandma always cooked this for me.
And this makes me happy all the time.
And next to oinarisan,
this gorgeous sushi roll,
it's like Japanese version
of California roll.
Itadakimasu.
Wah!
1,000% better than California roll.
Kanpyo maki.
In English it's, like, dried-gourd roll.
Itadakimasu.
Perfect sushi roll.
And last one, we have
pickles, radish pickles.
It's quite yellow.
It definitely has yellow No. 5.
Itadakimasu.
I'm gonna give them Grammy award.
And standing ovation.
Ah, the hot food at a 7-Eleven in the US.
We got a lot of options,
not as many as Japan.
I'm not quite sure what
some of this stuff is
just by looking at it, so
let me go down the list.
Nachos. They're the self-service nachos,
so they have the chips ready to go,
and then you just open them up
and add cheese and chili onto them.
Ugh. No, thank you.
Over here, these mini tacos.
Man, these look really, like ...
I bit my face.
Oh, man. They've been sitting for a while,
so I'll forgive them.
We also have wings,
crispy and not so crispy.
Pocket bean burrito guy. Look at that.
Over here in the roller-taquito section,
you can get a barbecue
bacon cheeseburger roller,
spicy garlic roller,
regular taquito,
Korean barbecue taquito.
Also, we have chicken sandwiches,
a black bean burger,
glazed cheesy barbecue meatballs.
Also at our 7-Elevens, you
can get a pepperoni pizza,
cheese, or seven-meat.
And also for hot dogs, we got
an exclusive hot picante dog.
No.
So, here are our hot food sections.
We've got steamed buns.
It's got pork and bamboo shoots.
And this is really standard nikuman.
So, next size up, we
have the doubled nikuman.
And next one, this little guy.
What is this?
Sweet beans steamed bun.
And last steamed bun is pizza bun.
You really are the pizza!
Delicious.
So, all these things, like,
around 100 yen to 200 yen or so.
So if you're broke, you
should definitely try this.
We've got these ones.
This one is called curry pan.
So deep-fried curry bread.
I wanna eat it. I wanna eat this!
I wanna eat this right now!
Itadakimasu!
Holy moly.
Um, it's freaking delicious.
And next one, croquette.
So it's basically got
potato and pork mince.
And last hot food we've got is corn dog.
So, this one right here is
a pretty Japanese-y one.
It's got ketchup and mustard,
and you just squeeze
this one onto this one.
All right, let's go, let's go,
let's go, let's go, let's go!
In Japan, we have these chicken options.
First, I'm going to start
with this one, karaage-bo.
So, in Japan, when you make
Japanese fried chicken,
you put some soy sauce on it.
So it has soy-sauce flavor
and also garlic flavor.
It's so freaking delicious.
So, this karaage-bo,
it's got one, two, three,
and four karaages.
We have fried chicken,
spicy fried chicken,
chicken nuggets.
Hot sandwich,
the Buffalo-style chicken slider.
The cheeseburger
and the bacon cheeseburger.
Look, I mean, can you
even tell which one's,
right, which one?
Huh?
I'm assuming, obviously,
this burger's been cooked.
More on this in the ingredients section.
7-Eleven in the US, and I think probably
here in Southern California,
has tacos and burritos.
Get yourself a chicken fajita taco,
al pastor taco.
Bet this one's good.
And a chorizo breakfast taco.
The spicy beef, bean, and cheese burrito.
This ain't any burrito, baby.
It's The Bomb.
Bombing out the toilet, good God.
You're getting this and
you're microwaving it there.
So if you're, like,
walking out the 7-Eleven
chomping on The Bomb,
like, better make it home in time.
'Cause oh, man, it's coming.
Empanadas, right?
Yuelei: Yeah.
I don't want this.
I'm gonna go ahead and put this in here
and then close the lid
like it's a coffin.
Go away forever.
All right, so here are my favorite bentos.
Let's take a look at this one.
It's called nori bento.
This one is a pretty popular one in Japan.
So it's got croquette,
a deep-fried fish cake,
fried fish with tartar sauce.
Kinpira gobo.
It's like Japanese traditional salad.
Pickles.
And as you can see right here,
it's got spicy cod roe.
Under this seaweed, it's
got rice and fish flakes.
I love this bento.
Like, when I was a student,
I think I would eat this every single day.
So, after my favorite one,
this one. Look at this!
So this one is a Korean-style beef bento.
Oh, man, smells so good.
Whoo!
Everything right here is so amazing.
Fantastic.
This is so mashisoyo.
Tonkatsu bento,
and it comes with this
sauce for this tonkatsu.
Look how thick it is.
So, outside from bentos,
we have soba, soba noodle.
Put this sauce first.
Put wasabi and dried seaweed.
And then you put water onto soba noodle.
It's getting moist.
And don't forget to put
green onions right here.
Itadakimasu.
So you put soba noodle in this box.
[slurping]
Umai!
I guarantee you can't stop eating this,
'cause it's so delicious.
Sorry I slurped the noodles.
Because Japanese people or Asian people
do make noises when you eat noodles.
We slurp.
Slurp!
Slurp right now!
They got the meals over there in Japan.
We got meals too,
like this ready-made ricotta-, Romano-,
and Parmesan-cheese-stuffed ravioli
topped with marinara sauce and mozzarella.
Ugh.
Just stop, stop doing this.
Stop, please.
Stop.
Oden.
So, oden is like Japanese
traditional hot pot.
It's got fish cake,
fried tofu, noodle thing.
This is made from potato.
Egg, radish.
In winter, when you eat this,
this warms you up, from your heart.
To your body.
And next, gratin doria.
So, obviously it's got meat
sauce and a lot of cheese.
Under this cheese, it's
got a lot of rice in there.
It's like Japanese Western food.
We have 7-Premium main dishes.
Naan and butter chicken curry.
And next we have 7-Premium side dishes.
Mackerel, grilled mackerel.
We also have mackerel in miso.
Saba miso is [chef's kiss].
Smoked tongue.
In Japan, it's a pretty popular item,
especially when you go to a
Japanese barbecue restaurant,
we order the beef tongue or pig tongue.
So this one used to be like this.
Smells so good.
So fancy.
It's marvelous.
So, after this sexy tongue,
we have sexy fish cake.
And look at this bar.
It's a chicken bar,
so it's like a chicken
nugget before it's fried.
Octopus and wasabi.
This is just raw octopus.
Kinpira gobo. It's sautéed burdock.
Hijikini, stewed hijiki seaweed.
And potato salad.
So, when I go home, my mom always cooks
this one, this one, this one.
I love you, Mom.
I miss Mom's cooking.
And next we have Premium Gold main dishes.
Shrimp with chili sauce.
Beef stew.
Hamburg steak.
Sandwiches, 7-Eleven.
Egg salad.
Peanut butter and jelly.
Turkey and cheddar
cheese on a kaiser roll.
So, we have the Italian-style sub,
but then we also got The Italian Job.
Turkey and ham with, is that
cheese in the picture there?
We got the smoked turkey and
Monterey Jack cheese sandwich,
and they separated the lettuce,
so you add it right before
you're ready to eat,
so it's still nice and crisp.
Salads, chicken Caesar salad.
We also have a pepperoni pasta salad.
So, here are my favorite sandwiches.
It's got tuna right here
and cheese and lettuce.
And the rest of these are ham and egg.
I thought this is normal,
but you don't have this one,
fruit sandwich.
So it's got a whole bunch of fruits.
It's got peach, pineapples,
and oranges on whipped cream.
So it's like cake.
So, here is 7-Premium drip coffee.
So I'm going to make
myself a cup of coffee.
Heyo!
And he just sits on here.
Ah! Ah ah ah!
Ah!
Mm.
All right.
Itadakimasu.
It tastes like shit.
So, for breakfast sandwiches at 7-Eleven,
you can get yourself a croissant
with ham, egg, and cheese.
Ooh, an English muffin with
bacon, egg, and cheese.
We also have English muffins
with sausage, egg, and cheese,
sausage biscuits,
and sausage, egg, and cheese croissants.
The 7-Eleven signature brand also has
mini doughnuts, chocolate,
cinnamon, crunch,
and, of course, powdered.
Madeleines.
7-Eleven has cookies right
at the register for a dollar.
You can get yourself some
macadamia nut cookies,
oatmeal raisin, sugar,
but there's also a
chocolate chip cookie one.
Baked goods, you get
yourself some muffins.
This is a blueberry muffin.
Coffee cake.
Crispy rice treat bar.
Notice it doesn't say Rice Krispie,
'cause you know that's copywritten.
Walnut fudge brownie,
bear claw Danish,
iced honey bun,
cheese Danish,
mixed berry Danish,
glazed honey bun.
I got these prepackaged, it
says "flavored snack pie."
That's a weird way of putting it.
Lemon, key lime, banana cream.
I feel like they used the
same -- that's the same.
That's Photoshop right there, buddy.
Boston cream, apple,
and the last one, strawberry cheesecake.
Key lime.
Look at all that cream in there.
It's key limey.
Oh, yeah.
Oatmeal!
That's obviously maple syrup right there.
But the first thing I
did when I looked at it,
I was like, "Wait, does
this have brandy in it?"
Boozy oatmeal.
You can put hot water in here, Joe.
Or hot milk, Yuelei.
Or hot whiskey.
Your boss won't notice the difference.
Well, at first.
Here we have Japanese type of bread.
Stir-fried-noodles-and-sauce bread.
We call it yakisoba pan.
Now, you may be thinking what
the [dolphin chirps] is this?
So, it's like hot dog,
but instead of sausage,
we've got stir-fried noodle inside.
Carb, carb.
It makes you fat.
Bread makes you fat?!
So, kids love this noodle and bread.
Itadakimasu.
Mm!
This one reminds me of my childhood,
me playing tags in the
mountain and chasing the girls.
Now a lot of girls chasing me.
This is a crab bread.
It's got two crab-shaped bread.
Now, the question is,
does it taste like crab?
It doesn't taste like crab.
Taste like just bread.
Pink bread.
It's a
cherry-blossom-flavored-coating bread.
This pink stuff is,
it's pretty sour.
It tastes like cherry blossom
and like my first kiss.
This is the salty, savory snack zone.
Ah, so much stuff.
And I've hit the "Food Wars" wall.
Hot and spicy cracklin
curls, the original,
and the fried pork rinds, chili lime.
I'm not tasting anything
pork-related to it.
Little pig guy there.
Little piggy guy.
You're on the menu, buddy.
Next, 7-Selects has
their own veggie straws.
This will be the trail
mix and mix-like section.
We got these
cheese-pizza-flavored snack mix.
You're gonna be a stinky boy
if you have a bunch of these.
Now they got the spicy ranch flavor mix.
And this last one, just sesame sticks.
For those of you who like
to get your trail mix
or your Chex Mix and then unmix them
and organize them and eat them like that,
7-Eleven has got the snack for you.
Oh, this is kind of a party snack mix.
Eh.
This is what I would totally
get, yogurt pretzels.
They put yogurt on there,
and, like, you're thinking,
"Oh, yogurt, that's healthy, right?"
I mean, it's just, it's the same as icing.
Now, you're looking at this going,
"Jack Link's beef jerky?
That's not a 7-Eleven brand."
No, it's not.
But as you can see,
exclusive 7-Eleven flavors.
See, this was like, "Hey,
Jack Link's, guess what?
We're about to push you
out of our shelf space.
So do a deal with us, or
you're gone completely."
And Jack Link's was like,
"No, I've got kids to feed, please!"
Brown sugar bourbon,
original recipe,
original.
Hickory-smoked bacon.
Like snacking on cheese and nothing else?
Full house, baby.
This one is mozzarella cheese
wrapped in hard salami.
Pepper Jack stick,
Gouda cheese to go.
Oh, the big one, the big
cheese, the white cheddar.
This ain't your grandma's cheese.
It's the big one.
Just two.
Cheddar cheese.
Colby-Jack, which is
like camouflage cheese.
Ugh!
Pretzels. Mini twists, non yogurted.
Pretzel nuggets. Ooh, gross.
These ones have peanut
butter inside of them.
Pretzel sticks. I feel like
there was a while there
in the early '90s when they were like,
"Chips are bad for you.
Eat pretzels instead."
And these are really salty, too.
A serving size of these is three.
I would get this assuming I'm gonna sit
and eat this whole bag in one sitting.
I'm not gonna do three at a time.
The whole bag is 1,160 milligrams,
50% of your sodium intake.
Mini rice cakes.
Chips.
7-Eleven has a bunch of
their own potato chips,
including the original, fiery hot.
Kettle chips, which are way better
than regular chips, again.
Spicy jalapeño, smoked Gouda.
Ooh, Gouda.
Barbecue, salt and pepper.
Ruffles rip-offs. We got
cheddar and sour cream.
Prime rib, I'm trying these.
And Buffalo chicken dip.
Prime rib?
Woof, smells terrible.
Oh, my God, that was so bad!
It's definitely not this.
Yeah, more like ground beef.
And instead of one of these fancy forks,
there'd be the plastic spork
that they have at 7-Eleven.
They're opening the bag with the spork,
meat's pouring out of it,
it's on the floor of a 7-Eleven,
with a guy mopping around it.
Nuts, baby. Nuts.
The rise and shine fiber blend
of a trail mix, whatever.
Antioxidant. Yeah, right.
Revive and thrive,
another antioxidant mix.
Should've just handed
these out during COVID,
would've bounced back in a week.
Cashew halves.
You like your nuts halved? Booyah.
You like your nuts wholed? Booyah.
Does it matter if they're whole or not?
Would that affect the
flavor at all? Who cares?
Spicy ranch pistachios.
And, of course, jumbo flavored
wasabi and soy nuts. Nope.
Wasabi will never touch my
lips again after that video.
So, here are my favorite instant noodles.
Let's start.
Ippudo ramen.
Man, I love this.
So, it's got some packets.
Dried pork.
It's a miso for the ramen soup.
Dried veggies.
And it's got noodles.
All right.
And you've got to wait for three minutes.
So while I'm waiting for
this, I'm gonna go this one.
So it's called Ippei-chan.
So it basically is a yakisoba.
Yakisoba is like Japanese
stir-fried noodles.
So, you put some hot
water until this line.
All right, so it's been three minutes.
Put this soup into this bowl.
Mix it.
Smells so good!
Bravo.
So, Ippudo has a lot
of locations in Japan,
including Tokyo, but this taste,
this flavor is totally the same
as the restaurant's serving.
So just get it at 7-Eleven.
Oh, shit, I totally forgot the, oh.
So, I put some hot water, but --
oh, shit!
I should have thrown the
water away into the toilet.
Gomen ne, noodles.
Let's make yakisoba.
[laughs] The volume of these noodles
gets a lot bigger.
OK, so put yakisoba sauce.
And flakes.
And most importantly, mayo.
Mayo beam!
Oh!
And mix it up.
Ta-da!
So, this is yakisoba.
We usually eat this,
like, at summer festival.
Pretty good, as always.
Next, we have tako-meshi.
Look at this. So, it's got green onions,
and I believe this is tako.
So, three minutes again.
Look at this final noodle.
It says ultra-spicy final.
You're going to be crying
because of the spiciness.
It's too spicy.
But I'm going to try this,
only for shooting purpose.
This is for you guys!
We can do it.
Clip: Never give up!
Oh, man, I'm so scared.
All right, so I think
it's time to eat this one.
So, I'm going to throw the
water away in the toilet again.
Let's go to the toilet.
And put yakisoba sauce.
All righty.
And the taste itself is
lighter than this one.
I prefer this one, but,
but,
this is the king ramen.
All right, so finally let's make
the freaking spicy noodle.
I call it death sauce.
In case I'm dead,
please find another Japanese host.
It was nice to meet you, Food Insider.
Go!
Oh, man, look at this.
It's not red, it's blood.
I don't want to eat this.
[coughing]
Ah!
Oh.
I'm not joking, I'm not joking.
Ah, ah.
It hurts!
Am I alive?
Am I not dead?
Am I in heaven?
Hell?
I feel like I'm in hell.
It's not all junk food at
the 7-Eleven, Joe and Yuelei.
They also have delicious
freshly sliced fruit.
Prepackaged and everything,
came straight from the ground,
and it comes in a
container that will be here
until the sun explodes.
This, I mean, this has to be an LA thing.
You can get mango with
tajin seasoning.
Automated voice: Tajin.
Fantastic combination.
Finally, grape cup.
7-Eleven also has its own
brand of packaged candies.
Sour gummy bears,
sour neon gummy worms,
sour watermelon wedges,
green apple rings,
gummy worms for catching gummy fish.
Heh-heh. You like that?
Fruit leather, whatever we call this.
Chili mango. Hell yeah, I'm trying these.
Sweetened mango,
and a sweetened fruit medley.
Not bad. Oh, a little
spicier that I thought, whoa.
There's also gummy bears and gummy sharks.
There's also gummy peach rings.
They got jelly beans,
and they got sour cherries.
7-Eleven Selects in the US also has
their own line of sandwich cookies.
Vanilla, pumpkin spice,
double chocolate, peppermint,
s'mores, the duplexes,
lemon crème.
Mm-mm-mm.
So, here are Japanese sweets.
Pink rice cake with red bean paste.
So basically it's like
cherry blossom mochi.
Itadakimasu.
Mm, mm.
I want to eat this under
the tree of cherry blossom.
Cherry blossom, pew.
Next, we have ninja gummy.
He's like ninja salaryman.
So, it's a hard gummy.
It's really tough, like stones.
[crunching]
Toppo.
It's like Pocky, but
the chocolate is inside.
I'm loving it.
Look at this cute guy!
Koala no Machi.
Koala's March Chocolate.
My favorite would be this one.
When I was a kid, I would
eat this every single day.
And this taste is so nostalgic.
Oh, little George is calling me like,
"Hey, I wanna eat this! I wanna eat -- "
Hey! We are filming right now.
Later, after shooting, OK?
"OK."
OK. We're good.
Pudding.
Please prepare the plate.
And you just do like this.
One, two, three, go.
The shape is like cherry blossom.
Look how jelly it is.
Mm!
This is the best pudding ever.
We had to go on a run to get more stuff.
That's why visually this
all doesn't connect.
7-Eleven's got macarons, French macarons.
Ooh, mini cheesecakes,
New York style and strawberry swirl.
These I can get behind.
Our 7-Eleven in the US has ice cream,
such as banana cream pie,
caramel butter pecan,
chocolate-covered strawberry,
double cookie dough,
cookies 'n' cream, sea-salt caramel,
strawberry-banana shortcake.
So, let's start with cold stuff.
We've got fried dumplings. It's frozen.
Frozen takoyaki,
frozen fried rice.
So, after these frozen
meals, I got ice cream.
Choco Monaka Jumbo.
So, Choco Monaka Jumbo
is like Japanese ice cream sandwich.
Ah!
Let me bite. Itadakimasu.
Sorry, it looks gross. [laughs]
So it's got ice cream,
and it's got chocolate in the middle,
and this crunchy on the outside.
Every Japanese people get this one
at least once in their life.
And last ice cream, I got this one.
Gorilla chocolate ice cream. [laughs]
I don't know what this is.
Ah.
Ah! Ch-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t!
Ah, sorry! Itadakimasu!
This is delicious.
Not only me, but Gorilla would love this.
Lot of exclusive drinks.
I don't know really where to begin,
so I kind of lined them up
by perception of healthiness.
So, all the way down
on this end, we've got
7-Eleven Select Go Smart
cold organic pressed juices.
This one's the tropical glow.
And this gross-looking one is, of course,
clean and green.
After that, we got these
prepackaged juices.
These are the 7-Select Farmer's Grove.
Cranberry cocktail, raspberry lemonade,
orange juice, of course, regular lemonade.
Then next up in the bigger ones
we have the 7-Eleven teas.
Peach black tea, sweet tea.
They weren't kidding, man, look at that.
Lemon sweet tea
and green tea.
Fruit punch, mango, guava.
Energy, come on, herbal tonic.
Herbal? This is herbal, guys? Yeah?
7-Eleven also their own brand of ...
are these considered energy drinks?
The Gatorades and Powerades and the like.
So Replenish, and of
course Replenish zero.
I'm assuming zero added sugar.
Orange mango, fruit punch, lemonade.
The cherry is clear.
What? Why is cherry clear?
Guava splash, orange mango.
♪ These are bad ♪
7-Eleven energy.
"Strawberry lemonade energy shot,
one and half times the
caffeine of a cup of coffee."
Oh, good God.
Undrinkable.
How bad does it have to
taste where this is too --
I couldn't get to this?
You've seen this show, right?
You'll see what I'll tolerate.
This, I can barely tolerate this.
Here's something that
they don't have in Japan.
They don't have Slurpees.
That's nuts, right?
Slurpees are -- how do
you describe a Slurpee?
It's like a flavored slush.
We have endless Slurpee flavors.
The ones currently you can
get here in America are
blue rocketberry,
blood orange,
Vitaminwater XXX,
blue raspberry,
blueberry lemonade bliss,
cherry, Coca-Cola,
Mountain Dew citrus, peach perfect,
piña colada, and pineapple whip.
So, here are Japanese exclusive drinks.
We have vegetable juice, of course.
Mm! Oishii.
A lot of Japanese salarymen
drink this one every morning
to get their day started.
So this one is for Joe.
Joe, you're missing a lot of veggies,
so you should drink this one.
Oi Ocha, my favorite green tea.
And these two are hot drinks,
black coffee and café latte.
And this is our first time filming this.
We have alcohol.
We have 7-Premium beer.
And this one is not beer.
It's like Sprite with alcohol.
It contains 9% of alcohol.
It's pretty delicious,
but at the same time,
it's pretty dangerous.
Japanese sake.
When you come to Japan, you can see
a lot of people drinking alcohol outside.
They're like [groans].
They are not dead, they're just sleeping.
They're drunk.
Whisky.
7-Eleven in the US has its own
private brand wines,
Yosemite Road, Trojan Horse,
Plot and Point, and Voyager Point.
It also has its own canned
wine brand, called Roamer.
Perhaps the reason 7-Eleven
has such a wide variety
of products in Japan is that
it's everywhere in Japan.
There are 21,215 stores in Japan.
That's crazy!
Which is nearly 30% of all
the 7-Elevens in the world.
Of course, all 37
prefectures have a 7-Eleven.
And out of all of them,
the city of Tokyo has the most locations,
with 2,850.
To put that in perspective,
the US has 9,417 7-Elevens,
and there's no 7-Elevens in 18 states.
As far as states, California has the most,
1,823.
But as far as denseness in area,
Las Vegas, Nevada, has the most, with 158.
In Japan, our hot dog is 290 calories
and 720 milligrams of sodium,
which is 31.3% of your daily allowance.
Our hot dog is 180 calories.
Ooh. How about this?
Our hot dog is 180 calories,
but for the frank only.
The stats, for some reason,
don't say anything about the bun.
But this isn't much better for you.
It's 570 milligrams of sodium,
so around 24.8% of your daily allowance.
Japan's hand-rolled tuna and mayo onigiri
has 258 calories and is very filling.
Remember this guy? The tuna sandwich.
Here in the US, ours is 420 calories
and lots of sodium, over 800 milligrams.
Fuck!
And in the US, a Super
Big Gulp of Coca-Cola,
this isn't Coca-Cola, is 44 fluid ounces.
It's 513 calories and 143 grams of carbs.
That's over half your daily intake.
In Japan, 7-Eleven does not disclose
the ingredients list of its
freshly made food items.
It does, however, tell
us the country of origin
for the raw materials for certain items,
like the fried food, yakitori, oden,
and Chinese steamed buns.
The chicken for our fried
chicken is from Thailand.
The pork for our sausages and hot dogs
comes from USA, Canada, and Japan.
The wheat for the buns comes from Canada,
the USA, and Japan.
And adzuki beans come from Canada,
cheese comes from New Zealand,
and the shrimp for the shrimp
chili buns is from Vietnam.
This is the pepperoni pizza in the US.
And it contains all this junk.
I mean, what's this thing?
Never heard of that.
What about chicken strips?
It's got all this stuff!
Just like mom used to make.
And, of course, the 7-Eleven
Select cheeseburger,
which contains ... [sighs]
sesame seed bun has enriched flour,
excuse me, enriched wheat flour,
wheat flour, niacin, reduced iron,
monoserititate, serotitititate,
calcium propionate as a
preservative, calcium sulfate,
royal beef patty got smoke flavor added,
and it's beef, encapsulated
salt, potassium ...
Is anything else after that?
Salt, spice, pasteurized
process American cheese.
Ah, cheese -- they're sitting down.
That's how long this is going.
My cameraperson just sat down.
A preservative, paprika,
and annatto color.
So I guess the last takeaway
from this video is that in the US,
some of our 7-Eleven items can be
a little bit of a gamble with your health.
Speaking of gambling, you know your boy
got some scratchers when
he was over at 7-Eleven.
Mm-hmm, OK. So there's
the winning numbers.
OK, so we didn't win anything on that one.
I have no clue how to do this.
Did I win?
If you haven't subscribed
yet, subscribe now!
'Cause we were filming this for six hours.
Hey, guys. Joe from "Food Wars."
Just wanted to pop in and let you know
that we are officially starting
a new "Food Wars" season
with a new country.
That's right.
Coming soon to the "Food
Wars" cinematic universe
is "Food Wars: USA versus ...
[drumroll]
India."
You may know him from his Netflix
India show, "Menu Please."
Please welcome to the
"Food Wars" family Nikhil.
What up, guys? My name is Nikhil Kini,
and I'm so excited to be joining
the "Food Wars" hosting team.
India, a land filled
with a million flavors,
delicious cuisines,
and here I am to talk about KFC,
McDonald's, Burger King,
Starbucks, and many more.
It's gonna be a blast!
Professional fast-food taster, baby!
Let's get it!
That's right! "Food
Wars: USA versus India,"
coming to you real soon
right here on Food Insider.
So be sure to subscribe so
you never miss an episode.